-We're here with Mason Hereford.
Thanks for being with us, Mason.
-Thank you, thank you.
-His cookbook
"Turkey and the Wolf:
Flavor Trippin' in New Orleans"
is on sale now.
We're so very happy
to have you here.
We're gonna start with a drink,
right?
-We're gonna start with a drink.
I don't know how to make those,
so we,
in true New Orleans fashion, are
gonna have a beer and a shot.
-Alright, start with the shot,
I'm assuming.
-Got to knock it on the table.
-Okay, great.
-Take it down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nicely done.
-Beautiful way to start.
Alright, so, a lot of your --
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah.
The restaurant business.
Oh, son of a -- Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so a lot of these are
spins on Southern classics.
-Yeah, exactly, but we like --
This is an example of a dish
that I just could not stomach
as a kid.
-This is the bologna sandwich.
-Just a flabby bologna sandwich.
-So, how did your family make it
for you when you were a kid?
-Yeah, so, my mom would give us
two slices of white bread.
I love my mom.
Happy birthday yesterday.
[ Laughter ]
And it would just be
yellow mustard,
American cheese, and bologna.
-Yeah.
-And it was really sad for all
of us.
-It's a sad sandwich.
-And in order to choke it down,
we put potato chips
right in the center.
-Okay.
-That would give it some life.
-Sure.
-It was either that or no lunch,
and, you know,
you got to have lunch.
[ Laughter ]
So, what we've done is
we've elevated that thing to
something we really like,
and we've involved
a lot of people.
So I brought you some white
bread from New Orleans,
baked by my friend David Weiss.
You're gonna cut it and butter
it, if you do not mind.
-Alright, let's do it.
-You'll notice, extra thick.
So, yeah, cut that off
and then go,
like, you know, thicker than
your thumb.
-Alright, great.
-So, if you have a thick slice
of white bread and you grill it
off, it's gonna be crispy
on the outside and still kind of
chewy and steamed on the center.
You've done three. I only needed
two, so that's great.
-Good. I thought we might both
have a sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
-So next you're gonna apply
butter.
-Okay.
-Apply butter, edge to edge.
-Edge to edge.
-All over.
-And I'm assuming
I can be pretty --
-Well, the butter is
a little cold,
so this is actually
an inconquerable task.
-Okay. It's actually not bad.
I think it's spreads better --
-And you did perfect. Here it
is, in the pan, ready to go.
-Look, we're gonna pretend like
I just did that. Alright, great.
-We're gonna move on.
Next, we're gonna have you cut
the bologna,
if you do not mind.
-Alright, great.
-This is actually perfect butter
spreading.
-Do you want to tell me
in advance
how many slices of bologna
you want?
[ Laughter ]
-Let's go with four.
-Okay, great. That, I can do.
-So, having tried this earlier,
I did find the serrated knife
was easier.
-Mm.
-So I recommend that.
-Okay. How thick are these?
-Not that thick.
Let's go more towards
this little sample one.
-Alright, great.
-Oh, man, you're good at that
too.
-Thank you.
-Better than me.
-I would say, it's like
an eighth of a thumb.
If we're gonna do it
all in thumbs.
-Eighth of a thumb?
Half of a thumb.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
-So we fry that?
-Into the pan we go, yeah.
So, we've got this thing high.
It's got enough fat in it,
we don't need to put
anything in the pan.
-Alright, great.
Alright, and so we
just did butter
in the pan for these, right?
-Yeah, so, what we did is we put
the butter on the outside
of this so we could have
the exact amount we wanted
and it would be
all over the bread.
And as we take it out of the
pan, what we're gonna do is
we're gonna lean the bread
against each other
after we toast it.
-Okay.
-And what we're doing is
we're gonna let
some airflow go around that.
-Okay.
-It's science.
-Yeah.
-It's resting just like a steak,
but perhaps for
a different reason.
-Most of the scientists I know
dress and look like you.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nailed it. They love that.
So, what's gonna happen here is,
the outside kind of gets
the crisp up, and the center is
not so soggy.
If you just put it down,
it wouldn't have
the structural integrity it
needs for all
this girthy bologna that we got.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, that bologna
is looking good.
Hey, so I want to ask, if you
can, while you're doing this,
your restaurant, there's two
categories on the menu --
sandwiches and not sandwiches.
As a lover of sandwiches, I find
that incredibly alluring,
how much you respect
and honor the sandwich.
-Yeah, if you think about it,
the sandwich is
the perfect vehicle.
I mean, I have one
that's already ready.
So the sandwich
is the perfect vehicle.
[ Imitates sizzling ]
-Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
-And so you have
a plate of food.
And the person, the diner,
can do anything they want with
that plate of food.
You have a sandwich,
you've got every bite
that you've given to the guests,
the diner, preordained.
You've decided exactly
how they're gonna eat it.
And every bite has to be
absolutely perfect.
So it's actually
a lot more pressure
than being like an actual chef.
-I agree, right, yeah.
-Alright, so, let's make
the sandwich.
We're gonna start with
mayonnaise.
-Okay.
-I'm a Duke's mayonnaise guy.
I got a Duke's tattoo
right here,
right next to
a tattoo of my wife.
-That's great.
[ Laughter ]
-So, yeah, corner to corner.
You got to get the whole thing.
-Okay, yeah, I gotcha.
-Yeah, 'cause some people
just do the center, and you
obviously fall in that category,
which is fine.
-Okay.
-No, no, no.
-Well, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, what's this?
-That's mustard.
-Okay.
Ooh, what kind of mustard?
Or should you just show me
the tattoo?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is my friend Villa's
mother's mustard recipe
that changed my life.
-Great, alright.
So, we got a mustard.
-Next is a big pile of
"shrettuce."
Other side. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
It's fine, it's fine.
-Yeah, of course it's fine.
-The lettuce has to be next to
the mayonnaise.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, shrettuce. Get it?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They all got it.
[ Laughter ]
-Next up --
-Chips?
-No, no, not yet, not yet.
Next up, we've got
the cheesy bologna.
-Okay, right.
Bologna goes on the lettuce.
-Yeah, and then the chips, and
you want a big pile of chips.
Yeah, there you go. Big.
Maybe even two-handed.
-Okay. And then put this on
and just smash?
-Yeah, put it on, take a look at
it for a second, admire,
and then, with the hand --
Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's take a bow.
-[ Mumbling ]